if you were expecting Naughty Dog to
tackle uncharted 5 after the lost legacy
DLC then you should probably reel end
your expectations
I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news update
and to stay up-to-date with everything
the studio's working on be sure to
subscribe this isn't necessarily written
in stone but Naughty Dog co-president
Evan Wells addressed the question in an
interview with Game Informer he said I
would say that Naughty Dog doing and
uncharted after this is unlikely I would
never say never but we've got the Last
of Us part two on our plates and there's
so much more other stuff that we want to
explore I'd say the likelihood is low
The Lost Legacy launches this year on
ps4 though the saga could continue if
Naughty Dog hands the reins over to
another studio if you want to dig into
another epic adventure in the meantime
why not check out our review for the
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild and
to keep up with all of gaming's biggest
adventures you're already in the right
place
[Music]
you